dear fellow scholars this is two minute
papers with károly on a fire so far we
have seen excellent works on how to
simulate the motion and the collision of
bodies but we have completely neglected
some aspect of videos that is just as
important as visuals and that aspect is
none other than sound what if you have
footage of objects colliding but no
access to the sound of the encounter you
obviously have to recreate the situation
that you see on the screen and even for
the easiest cases you have to sit in the
studio with a small hammer and a mug
which is difficult and often a very
laborious process if we can simulate the
forces that arise when bodies collide
what if we could also simulate the sound
of such encounters if you would like a
great solution for this this is the work
you should be looking at most techniques
in the fields take objects into
consideration as rigid bodies in this
work the author's extend the simulation
to deformable bodies therefore making it
possible to create rich clanging sound
effects
now the mandatory question arises how to
evaluate such a technique evaluating
means that we would like to find out how
accurate it really is and obviously the
ideal cases if we compare the sound
created by the algorithm to what we
would experience in the real world and
see how close they are
you
well pretty damn close I love this
simulation software works the most when
they are not only beautiful but they
somehow relate to reality and this
technique is a great example of that it
feels quite empowering that we have
these really smart people who can solve
problems that sound inconceivably
difficult thank you so much for checking
the series out if you would like to be
notified quickly when a new episode of
two minute papers pops up consider
following me on Twitter I announce every
upload right away I've put a link for
this in the description box thanks for
watching and I'll see you next time